SPEAKER 1: I've known Larry Arnn
for a quarter of a century now.
I was-- I served on the board
of his Claremont Institute out
in California.
And about 20 years ago,
he came to me and said,
this Hillsdale College place
has offered me its presidency.
And using my wise counsel,
I said, don't do that.
I mean, you're running
your own institute here.
What you say goes.
And you're going to work with
faculty and administration
and these wild kids here?
You know--
Happily, he ignored
my sage advice.
And it's one of the
best things that ever
happened to this institution.
I do think that--
[APPLAUSE]
I do think when the complete
history of Hillsdale
is written one day, I think the
years of Larry Arnn's tenure,
with the leadership of Bill
Broad back on the board,
will be looked at as the
golden years of Hillsdale.
It has been a privilege
to be with him.
He's a great man, in large
part because his partner is
a great woman, the lovely Penny.
[CHEERING]
And yeah.
He's a great man.
But for Leslie and
me more importantly,
he's a great friend.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Dr. Larry Arnn.
LARRY ARNN: Good evening.
I am a partner with Penny.
I'm the junior partner.
Pat is one of my oldest friends.
And he's so faithful
and consistent and calm
and possessed of good judgment.
And I'm grateful to him.
I thank Victor and
Mark and Molly,
who in their each
separate ways are
forces of nature and among
the most important people
in the world.
I single out Nancy
Johnson to thank,
who's the head of
our capital campaign.
[APPLAUSE]
Where is she?
Where's Nancy?
Yeah, stand up.
[APPLAUSE]
I came here just
about 20 years ago.
And there were three people
working in my office,
one of them Nancy.
And two of them,
including Nancy,
fled in terror
within two months.
She went to a more sane place,
working for John Salvini.
But I've never known her
not to do a thing well,
nor for that matter, John
Salvini or Rich [? Payway, ?]
who managed the
construction of the chapel.
And my colleagues-- you know
what I think, but I love you.
[APPLAUSE]
I said that in part because
I've been cranky this afternoon
because some of
you couldn't hear.
And I made the
point to somebody,
oh, it was so wonderful.
And I said, you know,
in modern times,
we will never get a
better opportunity
to explain the meaning
of Hillsdale College
than this morning.
And about 62% of the people
couldn't hear very well.
And you know, it tells the
college, we're not in prisoner
taking business.
We-- you know,
we're cocky, right?
We think we're the best.
And we think that's
not good enough.
So I apologize to you.
And if you want to hear--
I also noticed a funny
thing, and that is, it
was the people who
sat in the places
where they couldn't
hear very well who
were the most complimentary
about what I had to say.
[LAUGHTER]
What do you make of that?
But you can get a tape of
that if you want to see it.
And Justice Thomas was there.
And the choir was gorgeous.
And the building is,
you know, not bad.
[APPLAUSE]
So the last time I talked about
the past, what the college is
for, and then tonight,
I'm going to talk not too
long about the future.
It's easy to predict
the future in one way.
The college stands
for some things
that it claims are eternal.
Let's just say as
long as nature lasts.
So is there a time
conceivable when we won't
need to have a good character?
What is a good character?
It's-- we're this strange
creature is, right?
We have these bodies.
They have these needs.
They hurt.
And they feel pleasure.
And the first of primary virtues
concerned dealing with those.
Do you want to be a coward?
Do you want to be a dissolute?
Do you think you can mount
to anything at all if you're
either of those things?
Or any of the
other moral virtues
which lead up toward justice?
So as long as there
are people, there
will need to be character.
And all of these things, by
the way, I'm going to comment--
it's shocking that we
don't teach these things,
because they are, in fact,
the most obvious things
in the world.
Is there going to be a time
when we don't need to learn--
what is the thing about us?
We're the only ones, right?
I have a favorite
translator, although he's
idiosyncratic in the
way he translates.
The first sentence of
Aristotle's Metaphysics
is, "The human soul
stretches itself out to no."
Don't you see that in
yourselves constantly?
Don't you every day meet
something that Aristotle always
calls an impasse and aporia.
That is, you see two things and
they don't make sense together.
And that is an
opportunity for thinking.
And it's how we
figure out the world.
And we love to do that.
Indeed, much of our sense
of our value of ourselves
is that we can make
some sense of the world.
Learning.
Always.
Freedom.
If there's a
choosing being, if--
we have-- most of you saw
my dogs, our dogs, right?
Actually there are-- if
there's reincarnation,
and there isn't, then
you want to come back
as one of my wife's dogs.
And the most troublesome
one is my dog,
but she takes care of it.
It's the nature of our marriage.
And they don't choose.
Now, they select or
opt all the time.
They know when to beg,
and I indulge them.
But you know, we--
here's the thing about us.
We can do a thing and
commit ourselves to action
and then wonder for days or
years, was it the right thing?
Something stands outside our
actual actions and judges
whether they were right or not.
And given the capacity for
that, then, it's nature.
We ought to get to exercise it.
We need freedom.
And of course, because
we're made to talk
and therefore we're made
to live together under law,
we need laws that
protect our freedom.
And as long as there
are people, we're
going to need those things.
What do you want to know?
More than anything, what
do you want to know?
You have these moments.
I talked about it today.
But none of you heard it.
[LAUGHTER]
Don't you have these
moments when you're
taken quite away
from yourself, even
in the middle of urgent
things that are bothering you
or are compelling you?
And you stop and you go,
something occurs to you, right?
Something high, something
that calls, like the chapel.
You see things and you think,
some are better than others.
What does it mean, better?
Can't it only be judged in
relation to something perfect?
Don't you want to complete
the story when you start
making a hierarchy of things?
Which we can't stop doing.
I happen to be a boy.
And so, we boys--
girls are better civilized
than we are, in my experience.
They-- we boys, we like, if
they're sports teams, right,
we want to know,
like, who's better--
the 1927 Yankees or the
1962 Green Bay Packers?
They will never meet,
of course, you know.
But we just love
things like that.
Why?
Because we want to
know what the best is.
And when we rank things,
we find things in them
that seem more perfect
than other things.
And that means we're
always trying to go up.
Those are the purposes
of Hillsdale College.
And the claim is
that they're eternal.
Meaning, at least as long
as it is their nature.
So we know if they're right.
By the way, if they're
wrong, these 175 years
mean nothing whatsoever.
If they're not true, every
one of them today, then they
were never true.
If the Declaration of
Independence-- you know,
John Dewey and Woodrow
Wilson and those guys,
they're always writing that
it's somewhat outmoded, right?
But they say, really
good for its time.
And that's an
impossible argument,
because what it claims is that
it's good for beyond time.
And that means if it isn't
true now, it wasn't true then.
And if it was true then,
then it must be true now.
And so, the college
actually exists
to invite us to
face those facts.
And that's a term
that can't change.
What can change?
Everything else.
Do you think that
tyranny might be coming?
I do.
I don't-- I'm not a
conspiracy theorist.
I think it's open.
Look at it, right?
What it-- where is
it evident, right?
Justice Thomas was
arrested by my claim that--
and Justice Thomas, I can just
tell you something about him.
He's a student.
He's just-- you
know, in colleges--
see, late in my life, I
was 45 years old or so,
I started working in a college.
I had avoided it like
the plague before.
And this happens to
be a good one, right?
So I work here and like it.
But what do you learn?
You learn that it's
in the student.
And people who are
students by nature,
they get better all the time.
Justice Thomas is like that.
And that means you never
say a thing around him
that he doesn't note it down
and ask you about it later.
And so, today,
he's asking me who
is the student of Hegel with
whom John C. Calhoun studied
at Yale College?
Because I think-- and I'm not
speaking for him and I would
not do that, because he's
the greatest man I know,
and greater than I--
I think it might mean that
he's connecting things
that friends of mine have
connected for some time now.
And that is, this here
right-wing Confederacy
and this here modern
left-wing progressivism,
they might be akin.
Or as Churchill put the point,
the Nazis and the Communists,
they do differ just
exactly as the North
Pole differs from the South.
Look at them.
They're the same.
Well, he wanted, so I have to go
look all that up and prove it.
And you know, if I
don't, I'll be shamed.
And-- but I can.
Because, you know, just in
the last couple of years,
I verified it.
Because I heard it years ago
and I started saying it again
and everybody said, really?
That's what that's about, see?
And I can tell you in simple
terms what it's about.
We live in the age
of modern science,
and modern science is
different from ancient science.
Science is the Latin word
that means "to know".
Ancient science is
just seeing, to behold,
to love the things
that are higher.
To do it systematically,
true enough.
But if your idea is
rather, I'm going
to study it and test and
show how to change everything
the way I place.
Bacon says, "torturing nature".
That was born even
before German philosophy.
But in the 19th century,
these German philosophers,
right, they came to
understand what they regarded
as a great opportunity.
And philosophers are very
wise people, more than we are.
And so its-- one's reluctant
to talk about their errors.
And yet there's no
choice, because you
have to choose between them.
They thought-- they saw
things that they thought
might be disastrous, but
really, mostly was very hopeful,
and that is,
everything is change.
And we are all victims
and shaped by that change.
But now we know that.
We're the first
ones to know that.
And that changes everything.
Now we could become the masters
of the process of change.
We could become
our own creators.
And then at last,
we would be free.
Now, the definition of
freedom I gave earlier
is, God gave us volition.
The implication is,
we should use it.
And that's very simple.
That's an argument
in Aristotle, right?
Do you ever see
sled dogs running?
Isn't it a delightful sight?
And they're made
for that, right?
Now, imagine horses doing it.
They wouldn't be
very good at that.
They're too long legged.
Right?
And so, they're made for that.
And Aristotle says, well,
you can see that and see
they're made for that.
Can you see what a
human being is made for?
And we all know what
they're made for.
We see excellent ones.
And we all admire them.
Almost all the same, by the way.
I mean, leaving out of
account Bernie Sanders.
[LAUGHTER]
And see this idea that
we can remake everything,
because now we know
everything is change,
and we are dominated
by the influences that
come through change.
What if we could control
all those influences?
Do you begin to see why
the government would like
to control every single thing?
Why it's of concern to them what
we say in this room tonight.
Why they're not
impressed with the fact
that, fools though we are,
we have the right to say it.
They're thinking,
they can't say that.
They can't say that.
We will stop that.
That's the temper that grows up.
And it came into America, as
it came into Germany before,
through some very elite
thinkers, the best.
Right?
And it came to an America
and it spread, because it's
a very powerful argument.
It's easier to say
today because we live
amidst the bureaucratic age.
And we can see that that's
dangerous and arbitrary.
Or we here can.
Many people can't see that.
But back then, it
was pure hope, right?
Because we could set
everything right.
And even those great
ones, they didn't
think enough about the
meaning of that term "right."
Because if everything is
change, by what standard do
you know if a thinker's right?
And what's happened in the
country since that was born?
First of all, it has
known nothing but progress
anywhere in the world.
Reagan interrupted
it a little bit
in this country for a while.
Trump is fighting against it.
You know, maybe
artfully, maybe not.
You know, it depends what
you think about that.
But there can't really be much
doubt that he's fighting it.
Oh, I have an email today
from the regulatory czar.
I get my updates every day now.
And he says, next Wednesday,
something's going to happen.
Could I be in Washington?
So you guys are all here.
I don't know how to
think about that.
But tomorrow, I'm
going to figure out
if I can go to
Washington on Wednesday.
And I've got no idea
what's going to happen.
But whatever it is,
I want to see it.
You should watch the news.
Remember, a little
nerdy guy, Paul Ray.
This has never been set back.
What's it done?
Just think of one thing.
It is the most important
thing for the long term,
although it's not the most
important thing on any given
day.
Think of education.
You know how that's been remade?
I mean, it is
complete and thorough.
So you know, John Dewey at
Columbia and Woodrow Wilson
at Princeton and a few
other places like that,
they start going from
place to place to place,
and their apostleship,
their gospel,
is, we can set everything right.
Nothing should be in our way.
We can make it all fine.
Right?
Never mind what the
word fine might be.
Don't want to-- don't want to
spend too much time on that.
And then, the next thing you
know, it's spread everywhere.
And it remakes the face
of the modern university.
You know, there used
to not be departments.
I see, because he's so tall,
I see [? Caltop ?] over there,
right?
And I saw Whalen
somewhere before.
How many years
have we been taught
been talking about
how we can get rid
of all the departments
at Hillsdale College?
And we haven't got
rid of them yet.
But the core is
the big deal now.
See?
Because why?
The departments are places
of specialized knowledge
for the remaking of society.
And that's what John Dewey
analysis in the document that
founded the Teachers
Union for Colleges,
on whose blacklist
we are honored to be.
And that means that there isn't
any common sense way to think
about what's right and wrong.
There's only testing.
And so one of the things
that, when the department lies
to the university, one of
the things they founded
was the education department.
And if you think about that
for a minute, isn't that odd?
That an institution
of higher education,
there would be one
department called Education?
It's actually kind of stupid.
But what do they teach?
Right?
We have an education
department here,
but we don't have
an education major.
And the reason is, the
people in our department
are really smart.
Is Copeland here tonight?
He's been hanging around a lot.
I don't know.
He is the chairman.
Dan Copeland.
Anyway, they don't
study stuff anymore.
They study how to deliver stuff.
Understanding that the
stuff that's delivered
will be defined by
some central place.
And so teachers are
now delivery boys.
You know, my father, a high
school teacher in Arkansas--
Hillary Clinton, you know,
because there's a pattern,
right?
Bill gets elected governor.
The biggest thing is education.
She gets control of that.
Same thing with health
care in America.
And he just railed about that.
What are they doing?
Our school, where I've
worked all my life,
they think they can run
it better in Little Rock
than we can run it here?
And they never
meet the students.
Right?
I used to hear that from him.
And I would say, oh, dad,
you're just annoyed at them
because they're the local thing.
And they're typical
of the bad things.
He said, no, they're
worse than that.
And you know, my
life is a process
of understanding
my dad was right?
He was right about that, too.
So now, what is it?
Now-- I think it
was my daughter,
Alice, one of the
daughters said to me
that they were watching a
movie with some friends,
and that some of the people were
not such good friends anyway.
There was a dinner
and the women got up
and retired to another room.
And some of the girls
thought that they
had rooms where they
were incarcerated,
except for the
men left them out.
That's what
Victorian times were.
And I said, goodness
gracious, did they
never read Jane Austen?
It wasn't like that.
Well, they think
it was like that.
And they think that,
you know, do you
know the New York Times thing
that's going on right now?
69 project.
Is that what it is?
America was founded on the
day that the first slave
ship arrived.
OK, fine.
But did it arrived in America?
Because it must
have been earlier.
Except actually,
it was much later.
With a document that says
all men are created equal.
So they control what we know.
And that's comprehensive.
And it's everything else, too.
You never know when
you'll hear from them.
And you never know
what they'll say.
This kind of government has
to be hostile to anything
that's independent.
My son-in-law, Dan,
sitting over there.
Dan, stand up.
Where's my daughter?
Because she's off
somewhere else.
Yeah, yeah.
And you saw her today.
You may wonder why
she married Dan.
We don't know.
Anyway, I was making the
argument, and you know,
did you know that Winston
Churchill is a very great man?
I mean, really?
I'll be working on Churchill.
I still do all the time.
And we'll be in bed,
I'll be with opinion,
we'll take our computers to bed.
It's not an entirely
unromantic thing.
We have four children.
I'll be working away.
And I'll say to myself, Winston
Churchill was a very great man.
And she'll say, you've
said that, dear.
It's from him and
from Aristotle,
but first from Churchill, I
learned that statesmanship
is presented as the
guardianship of wisdom,
because, you know,
people who are wise,
they get that way
because they don't
go about urgent
politics every day.
And yet, they're not
necessarily practical people.
And somebody is
going to oppress them
unless somebody protects them.
Here's Winston Churchill
talking about Hitler,
about who his enemies are.
Venerable pastures,
upright magistrates,
world class scientists
and philosophers,
independent-minded
manly citizens,
frail, poor old women
of unfashionable opinion
are invaded, bullied,
and brutalized
by gangs of armed hooligans.
Why would they do that?
The answer is, this passion
for controlling everything
will brook nothing independent.
It thinks, it claims, that
it can perfect everything.
If only it can get the
power to control everything.
And since the scientific
experiment is the methodology,
it means nothing can be
outside that experiment.
I teach a course here, and
we read totalitarian novels.
There's about seven
of them that we read.
Various times, right?
But if you read Darkness
at Noon and 1984,
you see the spirit of it.
And most of the totalitarian
novels, not all,
are written by people
who saw this firsthand.
Indeed, we're complicit in it.
George Orwell waited in a
cell for three nights in Spain
for them to come get
him and shoot him.
And he was a communist
revolutionary
in the Spanish Civil War.
Arthur Koestler
was an important--
Darkness at Noon, he wrote.
Arthur Koestler was an important
functionary of the Communist
Party in Hungary.
And he, too, woke up
in fear of his life.
And they thought--
that set him thinking,
you know, really,
what have I done?
It's horrific.
And it's driven,
made more horrific,
by the fact that it's driven
by something good, which
is the wish to ameliorate the
difficulties of human life,
which turns into the root, the
wish, to eliminate them all.
Do you see what
it's like to raise
young children in this age?
I mean, young children,
18 to 21-year-olds.
That's our specialty.
They're really great.
They're almost human.
And they grew up
in a world where
they, at least in
the public discourse,
they haven't been told
anything except that they can
be whatever they want to be.
And we don't get that
much, because this
is a really weird place,
and it's hard to get into.
And the kids you get in
here learned a lot about it.
But once in a while they'll
say, well, you know,
I just want to become
whatever I can be.
And I always say good,
you should be an aardvark.
Or would you rather be a human?
Because we know
what that's like.
And we know what the
good ones are like.
We take that away from them.
This is a massive
and dangerous force.
It may overcome us,
I said two days ago.
I said, you know, this
is like the great crises.
The Revolutionary War--
that was a fight about who
is entitled to govern.
Which is a fight always,
when it comes up,
about what is the human being.
And the Civil War was
exactly the same thing.
Isn't this just like it?
Is it true that each of
us, in his common sense,
has a right to govern
his own life, which
is what God gave him?
According to a moral
and rational sense
that only we among
creatures have.
Or is it true that only people
who are experts and scientists
can really pick our way?
There's this guy
named Douglas Jay,
and he made the mistake in
the first socialist government
in Britain-- which beat
Winston Churchill--
he made the mistake of saying,
within the House of Commons,
in Churchill's hearing, he
said that mothers don't always
know what is best
for their children.
The gentlemen of
Whitehall know better.
Whitehall is the
governing center.
And you know, it was
just such a mistake
to say that with
Winston Churchill,
because Winston
Churchill has made
him famous to this
day for saying that.
That's the spirit, though.
And so, my last point is,
what do we do about it?
First of all, it's
overwhelming, right?
Everybody-- everybody
fancy, everybody elite.
All these fancy graduate schools
and medical schools and law
schools that our kids go to,
everybody at those schools
disagrees with us.
Sometimes, I think our
kids-- our kids are admitted
because they're really smart.
And you know,
they're impressive.
But sometimes, I think they're
admitted because of curiosity.
One young man who went
to Yale Law School
clerked for Clarence
Thomas later.
Really, a super young
man, important man now.
He-- it wasn't really
a slur, but at Yale, it
was said to him,
you're just a white boy
from Hillsdale College.
You're out of your depth here.
Now, I don't actually
mean to criticize the man.
This young man later
found out that this guy
was on the admissions
commission--
committee that let him in.
Why did he let him in?
He was curious.
What kind of the people
are those people?
Right?
And so now, we're
studied like specimens.
So if that's overwhelming, how
can we do anything about it?
Well, I'll just tell you
briefly what we're going to do.
I mean, I'm granting, of course.
Because, you know,
I want you know,
marvelous things
have happened here.
And we don't know how.
We just got up every day and
thought we knew what to do.
And we just got about it.
And we got about it together
every day, day after day
after day.
And, you know, that's a
pretty good way to work.
But we're not deluded that
we're responsible for all this.
But if great things
have happened,
maybe you should
try to extend them.
We're going to do two things.
One is this little place,
with its graduate schools.
You know, it's growing.
We're kind of
frightened by that.
It's going to be the most
intense atmosphere of learning
on the face of the earth.
It's already like that.
You know, coming here, it's
like joining the Marines.
Say goodbye to your 3.92 high
school grade point average.
This is serious now.
You know, I had a girl--
Steve Smith is here tonight.
He might be.
Steve Smith and I have an honor.
We once gave an A minus to a
girl who only got those two
grades in her entire life, from
kindergarten, other than A's.
And she cried in my office.
And she said, what can I do?
And I said, well, you should
probably try to do better.
And this year-- you
know, she was sobbing.
She was later our
valedictorian, by the way.
And she was sobbing,
and she says,
is there any chance
I can get an A?
And I said, no.
Get over it.
That's the wrong thing
to think about, right?
Well, the point is,
that's the ticket.
You want to help them,
you want to love them,
you want to nurture them.
They got to work.
They must not pretend
to achievements
that they have not made.
Now, when they fall,
you got to help them up.
And they do fall.
They don't bring me in when
they fall because they're
afraid I might kick them.
But I won't, right?
And this has got to be
tireless and relentless
and no compromises.
See.
And I will tell you,
everybody I work with,
and everybody on the board--
that Pat [INAUDIBLE] and Bill
[INAUDIBLE] lead--
that's what they think.
They don't expect us to quit.
Then what do we do?
Because this can get
better than it is.
And it's going to.
I mean, God granting.
That's what I call
the nuclear reactor.
The general counsel
Bob Norton doesn't
like me to say that it's
going to radiate the country,
because he thinks there might
be some liability in that.
I will say instead
that it's going
to inspire something
in the country,
and the means are laid out now.
We have founded more than 20--
oh, well, in Primus.
It was 900,000 when I came here.
It's soon to cross 5.5 million.
[APPLAUSE]
And let that stand
for the long list
of incredibly stupid
things that we do here,
because that thing
cost a fortune.
And you get it, right?
We don't ask for
money in that day.
And people send it anyway.
I don't get it.
It's really great.
And you know how many people we
talk to in a typical month now?
15 to 20 million, counting
the radio, all that.
And it means the college
has been famous--
could become famous, right?
Which means it's dangerous,
because bad people know
who we are, too.
Enemies, I mean.
We're going to keep
that up and grow more.
And then, we always
try-- and I, you know,
I figured this out
a long time ago,
because I have
this weird history.
I've worked in
nonprofits all my life.
And I never intended
to, but I did.
And I figured out
something about them.
The things that they make
that's the most difficult thing
that they make,
they don't actually
give to the people
who provide the money.
It's a triangle.
So General Motors that
makes cars, right?
They sell it to a person.
They use the car.
And they give
General Motors money.
That's a fairly
simple transaction.
But you know, I'm looking
around for students here.
There are some here somewhere.
Maybe they've gone to bed.
Probably not.
You know, you don't know them.
And we just lavish resources
on them and attention on them
constantly.
You don't get to see that.
And yet you're paying for it.
How do you make that work?
Well, I decided a
long time ago, you
have to do what you
do best for everybody.
And so we have two things that
now reach very large audiences
that are like that.
Well, forget the
events like this.
Somewhere between 15,000
and 20,000 people a year
come to Hillsdale
College events.
And we never sell tickets.
That, too, is really stupid.
But we have these 20
plus charter schools now.
And you know, that's
just a hell of a mess.
And lord, if Waylen and
Bill [? Broadbeck ?]
haven't hired my daughter
to try to fix it.
And she will.
And you know, it's great.
And there are problems.
And we're going to
sort the problems out.
And they're going to become--
I can tell you what
they're going to do.
They're going to become
the greatest collaborative
effort for school reform
in the United States.
[APPLAUSE]
They're just like
everything else.
Some of the people who
run them are superb
and some are not as superb.
Some of the teachers
just knocked the cover
off the ball and others not.
It's going to become a great
engine, so that the best
ones help everybody else.
And if you don't want to
get help, arrivederci.
We have these online courses.
And these two things are
two huge academic outreach
programs.
And they're both run
by children of mine.
One of them's Katie,
and the other, Kyle,
who, as I said the other
day, I've raised from pup.
He's a student of
Hillsdale College.
And you know, he's awesome.
I mean, he's not here, right?
And so, he's almost
finished with his PhD.
He didn't want to get it.
I made him do it.
And what-- there are 2.2
million people taking notes,
but they're getting
better all the time.
They're going to be an
enormous engine for teaching
to millions more than now.
So finally, when
they're elaborated,
there'll be two
things true about it.
One is, if you would like
to get a liberal education
in the second best way--
the best way, in seminars
with people who really know
and other people who are giving
their hearts to learning.
The second best way--
take these courses
and read these books
and watch them over and over.
And spit-- and make that
the activity of your life
outside your work.
You can get an A level
education that way.
And here, it's free.
And it's going to
cover everything.
And there are millions doing it.
And there will be, we
pray, a million more.
But then, take all that stuff
that we learned in the Barney
project, in K through 12,
it's just like college.
There isn't any reason
not to have classrooms.
We can afford it.
In fact, we're wasting masses.
Did you know that more
than half the employees
of the public schools
are not schoolteachers?
Which means half the
budget's shaved off
and goes somewhere else.
We can not just afford it.
We can double afford it.
But if you're not going to do
that because the schools are
so bad, homeschoolers and
private schools and any school
that want everything we get
great in the Barney project,
we're going to digitize it
and make videos about it
and put it online.
We've come to think
of the college
as the different kind of thing.
It's a combination of two
things that have not been
combined as far as we know.
One of them is, it intends
to be the best college.
It's not going to stop.
And we get up in the
morning every day, saying,
not good enough yet.
It wouldn't get better if you
didn't do that, by the way.
What's the second
thing is, it's going
to be a means of
learning for millions
and millions of people.
And it's going to
radiate that everywhere.
And I'll tell you
why it's important.
There are two reasons.
One of them is, that's
a very beautiful thing.
And everybody should
see a beautiful thing,
because then they will
know what God is like.
Also, they will understand
their own freedom and why
it is not to be interrupted.
And the second
reason is because we
live in an age of
confusion that has become
dangerous, threatening tyranny.
The only thing, ultimately, that
can dispel it is understanding.
This college was born 175 years
ago to give that understanding.
Not just here, even back
then, wherever anybody
wanted to learn.
You and God have given us
the means to make that big.
And we're going
to save the world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]